[Music]
all right let's see what rob has to say
in philadelphia pennsylvania rob welcome
to the ramsay show
hey how are you guys great how can we
help today
uh i'm in the middle of baby step two
while also saving for a wedding
and uh congratulations
thank you thank you uh i have a car
that's fully paid off that i paid 16 and
a half for and it's now worth 19 and a
half
so i was thinking of selling that using
that uh money to finish off the wedding
savings which is only 3 000
and then i wanted to attack my student
loans with the rest of that but i wasn't
sure how much to save for another card
how much uh do you have in student loans
uh 26 000
and you need to save another three for
the wedding but
uh 3 000 left to save for that how soon
is the wedding
uh it's in december
oh okay you got plenty of times bro save
your money keep your car dude
really
convince me otherwise
the car here's the thing when it comes
to selling the car it's not going to
create any cash flow because you don't
have a payment on it so it's not going
to make you money except for what you
get for it and uh you're still gonna
have to go buy another car in this
market which could be you know eight ten
grand right
right which leaves you with ten grand
after all said and done and all you know
all the effort you're putting into
selling this car so the question is can
you save up 10 grand and avoid having to
sell the car
quickly what's your income
uh 50 000
okay and what do you have in debt total
is it just the student loans or is there
something else
no just the student loans okay
well um
do you know if your fiance has debt
uh she's debt-free awesome
well
making 50k
you're gonna easily be able to save up
the 3k for the wedding right
right we'll put that in savings are you
guys paying for this all on your own
uh a third her parents the third my
parents and the third of us okay and
she's chipping in some and you're
chipping in some here your your part is
3k
that's left okay
i think you can save up for this wedding
and then go hard on the student loans
until the wedding happens
what what is it what is it about this
car you want to sell it
um i was just thinking that would be the
quickest way to get the student loan out
of my life and then i could just get by
with a cheaper car for now
do you have a cheaper car in mind
uh no but i was looking and like it
seems like the floor in this market is
like three to five thousand
yeah everything's up like a fred
flintstone car with no engines three
thousand bucks right now
pretty much
i don't think i don't have a pro if you
want to sell a car you don't want it
anymore and it's going to clear all of
your debts and whatever and you can go
get a car that's going to get you from
here in there that's not going to hurt
my feelings
i like
go ahead yeah my other thing is that i
work from home now and i don't really
use the car as is okay
yeah well then man sell it i mean
like george said you're not going to be
solving a long-term problem but i do
understand the impetus to feel like i
could expedite the next year of my life
pay off my student loans go into my
marriage debt-free pay for the get the
3000 bucks for the wedding yeah
yeah i mean if i'm in your shoes
personally i would sell it yeah i would
too because i don't care about driving a
nice car my car cost six grand i've
driven for five years now i have no real
intention or urgency to get a new one
and i just tried to sell my car to
george off air but that's for between
four and eight thousand making deals
we're not car guys so i mean i love the
the hustle from rob here wanting to get
the cash wanting to pay down this debt
quickly and really setting yourself up
for some amazing success in marriage
when you guys start this thing off debt
free if you can do that so i'm all for
it but there's no fire where i'm going
dude you got to sell the car so it's
your decision either way and if it's
going to give you the motivation to get
rid of this debt fast then i'm for it
final answer just know what you're
trading um you're gonna be trading a
seventeen thousand dollar car
or twenty thousand dollar car basically
for whatever you can scrounge together
for
eight to ten grand it's a good question
congrats on the wedding man